welcome back i had to because i was
hitting against the youtube 10 minute
limit but all i was saying is we said
you know cosine of minus a so i draw
drew you know a right triangle with a
and then i showed you minus a and i said
well all of all of the lengths are going
to be the same but now the direction of
and we're kind of assuming this is on
the unit circle if you don't remember
the unit circle
maybe you'll want to re-watch the videos
we have on that
but i'm just showing you that the cosine
of minus a is equal to this side over
the hypotenuse and this hypotenuse is
the same as this hypotenuse right
so cosine of minus a is adjacent over
this hypotenuse well cosine of a is
adjacent over this hypotenuse but it's
the same thing so we know that cosine of
minus a is equal to cosine of a and
actually by definition that that makes
it a i don't want to confuse you too
much but that makes cosine an even
function and i'll show you more actually
i should do a whole presentation on even
and odd functions
let's see what sine of minus a is
sine
of minus a is equal to so this is minus
a
so it's this side so it's the minus
length of you know i mean if i let's
just say let's call this x
let's call this y and let's call this
well let's leave that h right if that is
x this is y this length is y then this
length right here is minus x right
so the sine of minus a is minus x over h
minus x over h right what's the sign of
a
sine of a is equal to
this is a opposite over hypotenuse x
over h
is x over h
right so sine of minus a is equal to
minus 1 times x over h
right or this is just the same thing as
i mean if we could multiply both sides
of this by minus 1 minus x over h right
so sine of minus a is equal to minus
sine of a
oh so so let me clear this out and and
and rewrite this identity now as you can
see all i'm doing is i'm just playing
around with with triangles and showing
you that you know just using the basic
sohcahtoa you can actually
discover a whole set of trigonometric
identities
so let's clear that and you know you
might it's a lot of these are it is
useful to memorize i normally don't
advocating advocate memorizing but it's
it's helpful just to do things quickly
but i'd also advocate being able to
prove it to yourself so if you ever
forget it and you don't have you know a
cheat sheet available you can prove it
to you can prove it and if you ever have
to teach it then you'll be i think uh
able to explain the under underlying
themes a little bit better so let's
clear this let's let's see if we can
discover some more trig identities
so we know that
so let's see if we could let's see if we
had sine
what's sine of a
plus pi over 2.
a plus pi over 2. well we could use our
our handy sine of a plus b
identity which we have already proved so
we can use it now
so that tells us that it's the sine of a
that equals the sine of a
sine of a
times
the cosine of pi over 2
times the cosine of pi over 2
plus
the sine of pi over 2
and we're in radians of course i could
this could have been
90 degrees instead if we wanted to be in
degrees
sine of pi over 2
times the cosine of
a right
well this equals the sine of a
what's cosine of pi over 2 or cosine of
90 degrees well that's when we're on the
unit circle we're pointing straight up
and so the x coordinate is is zero i
could draw it out but i think you might
want to draw the unit circle and figure
it out for yourself or if you don't you
know use on a calculator but you will
learn that it is 0 cosine pi over 2 is 0
plus sine of pi over 2. for the same
reason we're pointing straight up on the
unit circle so the y coordinate or the
sine coordinate is is one right on the
unit you know at one where it
essentially is the point zero one on the
unit circle
so sine of pi over two is one
so then
and then times cosine of a
so sine of a times 0 is 0 1 times cosine
of a is just cosine of a so we we have a
new useful trig identity
excuse me
sine
of a plus pi over 2
is equal to cosine of a
fascinating so really this is just
telling us that cosine of a is is the
same thing as sine of a shifted so if we
were to think of this graphically if we
were to think of you know if we were to
draw the graphs if you if you shift side
the sine graph to the left by pi over 2
you get cosine you get the cosine graph
and and if you haven't learned about
shifting yet don't worry about that or
you might want to actually graph the two
and and i think you'll get a sense of
what i'm saying
so let's do uh
i don't know
well another and another way to rewrite
this exact same thing is the sine of a
sine of a is equal to
the cosine
of a
minus pi over two
right if you just you know let's say i
said that b is a
is a plus pi over two right let's just
say i said b is equal to a plus pi over
two
then we could say that this is you know
this is b
and then this would be b minus pi over
two i'm just switching around variables
i'm doing this in a much more
loosey-goosey fashion than i normally do
a lot of videos but i want to show you
that a lot of this trigonometry can just
be
you know it's just kind of discovery
what's uh
what's sine
of a
minus b oh that looks like a new one
doesn't it
well we we let's let's try to figure it
out well that equals
sine
of a
cosine
of minus b minus b
plus sine
of minus b
times the cosine of a
right
well what do we know about the cosine of
minus b we just before i cleared the
screen we just figured out that the
cosine of minus b
since it's an even function is the same
thing as the cosine of b
so we can rewrite that as that equals
the sine of a
cosine of b
and then what's the sine of minus b
well that's the same thing as the
minus sign of b in that last the last
that's what we just
proved that the sine of
minus b that this is equal to minus sine
of b
you could draw the triangle in the unit
circle if you don't believe me but we
just did that so that we could say that
that is equal to minus sine
of b
cosine of a interesting i encourage you
to do the same thing with the cosine of
a minus b these are all just you know
we're using you know one or two or three
trig uh identities together and and
trying to come up with new things and
and i think at this point we've
literally gone over everything that
almost every trig identity you've you've
seen in your book you can
you should be able to to to get there
somehow just by keep on playing and
obviously all of these identities you
can you know you can invert the signs
and the cosines and the tangents and you
can get
you can get identities for secant and
cotangent and cosecant and
and and keep keep playing around and i
encourage you to do so and do it
graphically
draw the triangles i'd also it's also
interesting to sometimes actually draw
the graph on the xy plane of say you
know cosine of
of x plus pi over two or cos sine of x
plus pi over two or sine of x and i
think i'll in the future i do a video
where i i really do explore all of that
well i hope i haven't thoroughly
confused you i want to just kind of show
you that
a lot of trig it's it's really it all
comes from sokatoa and playing around
with sokatoa and triangles and you can
pretty much get
you can pretty much solve for
everything you learn in trigonometry and
if you don't have socato at least the
unit circle definition
which is actually better because it's
more extensive but anyway that's all for
now see you soon